Taylor is with us in Phoenix Arizona
hi Taylor how are you hey Dave how you
doing today
better than I deserve how can I help I
had a quick question I found out I went
to school started school going for my
business management degree and I stopped
school for a certain reason because of
the hours I was working the school
notified me that I had about eight
hundred and twenty-five dollar balance
that I had to pay that was at a
discounted rate but I just received an
email from a company called Fed loans
and so I called them and I was trying to
figure out what it was about and I was
able to contact someone there and they
said that there was a ten thousand
dollar balance that I owe now from tool
and service traffic way how do we get
from eight hundred and twenty five to
ten thousand exactly i I don't know
I did try contacting the school again I
got a voicemail and I left one from you
know for the financial department to
call me back but they haven't got back
to me yet
when did you get the settlement offer of
eight hundred twenty-five dollars from
them uh that was about six months ago
and do you have that in writing I guess
and that is completely paid off and you
paid it so I had an email or some kind
of form of writing it says pay 825 and
you will owe us nothing it's actually a
certified letter Oh better yet okay and
you know your proof that you paid the
825 okay
did you borrow money to go to school
that you didn't think of um the only
thing I can think of is I told out a
FAFSA form that doesn't put you in debt
but he did
that I talked to he said that that were
you know the 825 I borrowed from the
school he said that that balance was
just pertaining to school not retaining
the loan but I mean if you pay ten
thousand dollars come into your hands
you wouldn't know it right
I mean did how did you pass how did you
pay for school what did school cost and
did you pay cash for it no it's not okay
how did you pay for school I like I said
I filled out the FAFSA form but honey
FAFSA doesn't loan money FAFSA is just
you you applying to get a loan you must
have borrowed $10,000 to pay your
tuition okay how long were you in school
for about six months okay and what did
the school cost to go to school there if
let's just pray tell one word to write a
check is about let's say it's about $600
per semester you were only there one
semester right that's the cheapest
school in the history of the world is
this is this a Community College it's a
university it's Argosy University Argosy
yes an online deal correct and it they
also have in class as well okay if it
costs $600 to go there and you paid them
825 how was that a settlement they they
did the it was a loan differential came
in I guess that they mentioned or a
discounted rate because they said the
overall the amount that I had was just
over $3,000 how could it be $3,000 of
its $600 to go there for six months I
you got your your numbers are so screwed
they don't even make
it's okay here's what I'm thinking that
must have happened all right you need to
get on the phone with Argosy freaking
online university and find out what they
charged you for this entire semester you
went there for one semester it appears
you borrowed seven or eight thousand
dollars to go there for one semester and
it appears you signed the loan documents
to do that that's what it sounds like
but you need to actually understand what
the flips going on don't just pay these
goobers because they call you on the
phone and say you owe the money but you
need to go okay hi that's what happened
I borrowed money to go to this stupid
school and they freakin overcharged me
dramatically for one semester of online
classes she's and then you vanish signed
the form that called a loan document
that allowed them to put that pay that
money directly and then you paid 825 out
of your pocket in addition to what you
borrowed that's what it sounds like
happen and I also checked my credit
history and it shows that fed loan is on
my credit history but the balance that
shows that I borrowed was $3,600 okay
well let's just try to say let's start
with that there's two different
equations here that this conversation
started with you have no idea where the
$10,000 came from now you're telling me
it appears you borrowed thirty-six
hundred that would have been information
it could have used about four minutes
ago okay now so you know that so it does
appear that that's what's happened you
borrowed three thousand six hundred
dollars plus payday 25 to go for one
semester which is still a rip and but
but then they've tripled this on you
with a bunch of late fees and gotchas so
now let's go back to that as our
assumption and sell you how to solve it
let's say you dig into this and you need
to dig into it and find out what you
borrowed okay if you did truly borrow
not just what's on your credit bureau
because I can put crap on your credit
bureau fraudulently okay but I could put
crap on there that says you owe money
and that doesn't mean that's what really
happened so you need to find out from
the University what you really borrowed
and what you really paid them as
if it was $3,600 if that is an accurate
figure
then you challenge these idiots that
called you on the phone and go there's
no possible way owe you $10,000 I
borrowed thirty six hundred six months
ago
you don't have a five thousand percent
interest rate over there okay right it's
absolutely ludicrous no I don't know you
ten thousand dollars
no I'm not gonna pay you ten thousand
dollars and I owe you thirty six hundred
dollars plus some interest and maybe a
late charge or two but then you get
about the business of paying that
thirty-six hundred off as fast as you
can and here's a rural tailor never
again sign a loan document never again
sign a document of any kind less you
know what to flip you're signing and
know exactly what you're getting into
the mistakes like this can set you back
decades if you're not careful so dig
into this this time dig all the way to
the bottom of it find exactly what the
facts are and then based on the facts
you've got then you negotiate with these
people calling you that it appears are
trying to rip you off by tripling this
debt but that's what happens when you
get involved with crap like this I'm
sorry you're facing it but watch what
you're doing this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and say you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind
you